[Musique]
bonjour est heureux de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de cette ut qu
aujourd'hui nous sommes à l'estaca pour
les rendez vous des acteurs de
l'immobilier d'entreprise alors que
représente l'immobilier d'entreprise à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines sommaire nous
ferons un point avec benjamin lebeau
directeur de l'investissement de l'asec
management ogm il nous expliquera
pourquoi il est important d'investir
dans le bassin nous irons aussi à
guyancourt découvrir le nouvel hôtel
ibis habile à roye et nous verrons
pourquoi ils ont choisi de s'installer
ici et puis nous interviewons christine
turquet de beauregard responsable du
développement en immobilier d'entreprise
sur les forces et les faiblesses du parc
immobilier saint quentinois débutons
avec cette infographie qui nous
permettra de faire un point sur
l'immobilier d'entreprise à saint
quentin en yvelines alors saint quentin
en yvelines c'est 53,4 millions de
mètres carrés de parcs et de bureaux le
bassin est le leader du marché de la
deuxième couronne devant marne-la-vallée
cergy et vélizy au total on à 142 mille
emplois ce qui représente 25 % des
yvelines six pôles économiques 4,6
millions de m² d'immobilier d'entreprise
donc 50% en bureau 20% d'activité mix et
12% en entrepôt et logistiques nous
avons pu voir les forces du parc
immobilier de notre bassin des sociétés
comme au jir elle contribue à travailler
avec l'agglomération car il y a des
aspects très intéressant ainsi nous
allons en discuter avec benjamin lebeau
directeur de l'investissement de l'asset
management ou girel bonjour monsieur le
bourg
alors pourquoi il faut investir ici
pourquoi il faut investir ici alors
c'est je dirais il faut notre
investissement il concerne une typologie
des actifs spécifiques nous sommes sur
la typologie activités donc qui est à
destination de fournir un outil de
travail pour plutôt des pme pmi et et
artisans ou des établissements de taille
intermédiaire et le marché de saint
quentin en yvelines est un marché mature
de ce point de vue là avec un réseau
d'entreprise existants qui constituent
des prospects potentiels pour pour
le projet que nous développons vous avez
beaucoup de demandes pour venir ici à
saint quentin de demande extérieure ça
arrive notamment le premier contrat de
réservation nous avons signé sur une des
cellules du village est une entreprise
qui cherchait une implantation en ile de
france et qui a et qui a réservé donc
une cellule de 300 m² au sein de notre
village mais l'essentiel de la de la
demande locative est et à l'acquisition
porte sur des entreprises qui sont qui
sont d'ores et déjà implanté sur le sur
le territoire ou à proximité et quelles
sont nos forces en fait c'est moi à part
le réseau routier alors la force est
effectivement d'avoir d'avoir su en tout
cas proposé ou en tout cas nous avons
réussi à identifier du foncier
disponible pour développer des
opérations neuves sur ce territoire ce
qui est parfois une denrée rare
et les forces et c'est effectivement là
je dirais la connexion avec les axes de
transport qui est qu'il ya un élément
important puisque il faut il faut
pouvoir rayonner pour les entreprises
qui viendront
beaucoup et je dirais c'est ce tissu
économique dynamique qui voit là
constituent le le
la sphère dans laquelle on va trouver
nos utilisateurs et pour lesquels ont
construit ces opérations quelles sont
nos spécificités par rapport aux locaux
est ce qu'on a quelque chose en plus
est-ce qu on est très concentrés en ce
qui concerne les entreprises
par rapport aux entreprises locales
mondiale entreprises locales
je pense que les entreprises locales
sont sensibles à l'ensemble des efforts
qui peuvent être faits à la fois sur
l'attractivité du territoire à la fois
sur le sur la
connexion également en termes de en
termes de transport
et d'une façon générale tout le confort
de travail et ou d'habiter sur le
territoire donc à partir du moment où
les entreprises sont effectivement
travaille bien et se sentent bien dans
un environnement où dansent sur un
territoire elles ont tendance à rester
et et voilà et le l'objet c'est
effectivement de soi de pérenniser leur
implantation sur le territoire et on y
travaille avec saint quentin en yvelines
soit éventuellement même d'attirer des
entreprises pour pour montrer les
les a tous cas ce territoire avec cette
offre immobilière qui on essaye d'y
participer et doit être adapté aux
besoins des utilisateurs j'ai encore
beaucoup de choses à faire c'est entendu
boum c'est en trop important si vous
vivez pas de mission quand vous alors
je dirais l'opération en blanc est
forcément une opération risquée
là on est au début de la
commercialisation de notre opération qui
est donc un village de 6100 mètres
carrés un bâtiment de 5200 donc voilà je
dirais chaque chose en son temps et
à rassurons-nous et
parvenant à achever cette
remplissage de nos de nos de nos locaux
avant de avant d'entamer la suite
puisque c'est aussi de l'expérience
qu'on aura sur le temps de
commercialisation et le et le type aussi
d'entreprise qu'on arrivera à tirer sur
le territoire qu'est ce que c'est dans
deux entreprises du territoire donc un
marché en deux gènes ou est ce que ce
sont essentiellement des entreprises
extérieures qui nous permettront de
mieux affiner la stratégie pour pour les
événements et les étapes suivantes nous
imaginons que vous avez déjà une idée de
qui pouvait venir dans ses futurs locaux
n'ont cessé tous et où justement le
risque de l'opération blanc c'est que
nous développons nous développant un
produit qu'on essaye le plus flexible
possible et qui nous a semblé adapté à
la demande pour ensuite travailler avec
des agents en l'occurrence on a deux
agents qui sont mandatés sur le sur
l'opération pour justement faire
correspondre l'offre avec une demande ça
va merci
croise les doigts et on y travaille en
tout cas plusieurs merci merci vous avez
pu le voir la ville de saint quentin en
yvelines est attractif en termes
d'immobilier d'entreprise nous avons
décidé de faire un focus sur l'hôtel
ibis a vu la roi qui vient juste de
s'installer alors pourquoi s'est il
installé dans l'agglomération focus sur
l'hôtel ibis de guerre au cours
la chaîne d'hôtellerie accor n'a pas
hésité lorsqu'elle a pu s'implanter dans
la ville de guerre en cours avec son
ibis styles libye style ce sont des
hôtels dit économiques qui ont vocation
à recevoir des clients d'affaires
le site en face s'est imposé tout
naturellement de par sa proximité
géographique avec l'entreprise renommée
également inti colas bout de
construction safran ben voilà il ya
quand même
naturellement quand l'opportunité s'est
présentée elle a été saisie puisque
l'emplacement est vraiment
super
et pour séduire les clients l'hôtel
s'est inspiré de l'artiste hollandais
pieter mondrian mais pas seulement
l'architecte s'est inspiré effectivement
de lui et également du technocentre qui
appareille également des lignes assez
épuré ont trouvé que c'était intéressant
de faire le lien au travers de mondrian
pour décorer l'établissement
est en fait on a essayé de créer le lien
entre le technocentre et les l'hôtel et
du cou quoi de mieux que mondrian pour
faire le relais entre entre ces deux
sites service est pour le moment le pari
est réussi l'hôtel attire de la
clientèle est souvent complet le mardi
et le mercredi
alors pourquoi l'agglomération a mis en
place cet événement nous allons discuter
avec christine turquet de beauregard
responsable du développement en
immobilier à l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines bonjour alors
pourquoi avoir mis en place cet
événement alors en fait nous organisons
ces événements pour réunir l'ensemble
des acteurs de l'immobilier d'entreprise
que ce soit des conseils en immobilier
des promoteurs des investisseurs des
propriétaires pour les mettre autour de
la table et leur présenter les
évolutions du marché de saint quentin
leur présenter les tendances et puis
faire un tour de un tour de table avec
eux savoir quels sont les projets qui
sont en cours actuellement ceux qui
doivent être développées et qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire surtout pour les aider
alors c'est intéressant de venir
investir à saint-quentin dites moi oui
tout à fait saint quentin est une ex
villes nouvelles qui fonctionne très
très très bien pour preuve nous avons
quand même des grands groupes comme
mercedes benz qui s'est implantée il n'y
a pas très longtemps le crédit agricole
qui est le deuxième campus
d'ile-de-france maintenant avec un
nouvel immeuble de 20 mille mètres
carrés donc qui conforte sa position sur
le territoire des extensions de renault
des extensions de tous ces grands
groupes mais également de tous les
bureaux d'études tous les en fait les
entreprises viennent parce qu'il ya les
donneurs d'ordre sur saint quentin voilà
le l'intérêt de venir à saint quentin
donc c'est l'une de nos forces mais
dites moi les autres forces qui a dans
l'agglomération pourquoi il faut venir
ici c'est d'user mois voilà alors nous
sommes un peu victimes de notre succès
puisque à l'heure actuelle sur le
territoire de saint quentin nous
arrivons maintenant à un territoire
matures avec une pénurie de foncier et
donc ça c'est un petit peu problématique
alors pas pour les grands groupes parce
qu'on renouvelle en fait la ville sur la
ville donc des immeubles obsolètes sont
démolis et reconstruits pour accueillir
les entreprises dans des locaux de
qualité en revanche pour les pme pmi qui
volent des petits clé en main environ
entre trois et six mille mètres carrés
on a pratiquement plus de terrain à
commercialiser pour pour cette cible la
même avec l'agrandissement de
l'agglomération alors heureusement si on
les nouveaux territoires c'est un
territoire également qui mute et donc là
nous allons avoir d'ici quelques années
la possibilité d'avoir du foncier
disponible
qu'est ce qui attire ces entreprises
c'est le prix c'est la proximité avec
paris alors bien sûr la proximité avec
paris et les prix de loyer qu'ils sont
inférieur à paris et la première
couronne
et puis surtout je veux comme je le
disais au début c'est surtout les
grandes entreprises qui sont là et qui
font travailler en fait leurs sous
traitants leur but et c est en fait ce
qui est important sur 50 ans c'est qu'on
a toutes les filières représentées
aussi bien les filières numérique les
filières financières automobiles
transport et donc on peut comme ça
capter un petit peu l'ensemble des
entreprises et c'est une grande force
parce que nous ne sommes pas un
territoire mono filière qui est
dramatique quand on est territoire mono
filière si la filière s'en va toute
l'économie s'écroule quand vous faites
ce type d'événement quels sont les
retours et déjà qu est ce que vous leur
dites alors on leur présente les
nouveaux projets sur le territoire on
leur présente les chiffres et là j'ai eu
justement certains acteurs que nous
avons invité qui n'investissent plus ou
qui ne travaille plus sur le territoire
et qui ont été très surpris justement
des chiffres qu'on leur a présenté et ça
leur a donné envie de revenir investir
sur le territoire donc ça c'est quand
même un pari important et voilà la
nécessité de ce genre d'événement c'est
toujours parler du territoire de saint
quentin c'est pour ça que nous sommes
présents sur des salons comme le fit me
le mipim parce que si nous ne sommes pas
présents en fait il ya une telle
concurrence entre les territoires
d'ile-de-france qu on disparaît aussi
très vite quels sont les types de
chiffres qui sont les chiffres qui les
ont surpris alors le taux de vacance qui
est inférieur à 10% sur
que ce soit sur l'immobilier de bureaux
du mobilier d'activité ce qui est un
chiffre relativement faible
le peu d'offres neuves que nous avons en
fait
on a deux cent cinquante mille mètres
carrés de projets en cours dans les
cartons qui sont prêts à être développés
qui ont des permis de conserver obtenu
des agréments obtenus et donc qu'ils
sont prêts à sortir et qui attendent des
utilisateurs et donc ça ça les surprend
parce que ils imaginent que saint
quentin en yvelines qui a plus de 40 ans
il n'y a plus rien à faire sur le
territoire alors qu'en fait fi il ya
encore des choses à faire et c'est ça
qui les surprend lors de ces événements
eh bien merci à vous merci
et tout de suite on passe à l'agenda et
on reste dans l'immobilier d'entreprise
avec le simi qui se déroule du 30
novembre au 2 décembre au palais des
congrès à paris durant l'événement
plusieurs conférences réunions et
exposants seront présents lors de cet
événement on passe à la deuxième édition
de la journée tedx saclay 2016 à l'edf
lab paris saclay à palaiseau en
partenariat avec saint quentin en
yvelines l'événement permet de présenter
des idées innovantes devant douze
personnalités remarquables tels que
thierry marx le chef étoilé
la journée se déroule le 30 novembre
2016 7,8 écossais fini prochain rendez
vous le 8 décembre nous ferons une
visite du sky cube bonne journée à tous
[Musique]